[Music]
this great big story is made possible by
Lexus experience amazing the Harvard
brain Bank is one of the largest brain
banks in the country at the moment we
house approximately 5000 brain specimens
[Music]
my name is Sabina Bogota
I am the scientific director of the
Harvard brain tissue resource center
which we affectionately call Harvard
brain bank our mission is to collect
brain specimens store them characterize
them and then redistribute them out to
investigators across the world the do
research on the human brain and in
particular own large number of
neurological and psychiatric brain
disorders such as schizophrenia bipolar
disorder Parkinson's Huntington and many
others
the brain Bank never sleeps we have two
sets of people that are gonna called
24/7 we have a very limited time window
from when the person passes away to the
time we need to be done with this all
processing so this is gonna be your
first train late at night right we have
to do it in less than 24 hours our
courier will bring it from a plane
hospital to the brain Bank so just put
it out here so we're gonna take
ourselves it would be a dissection is
ready to dissect a brain
[Music]
that involves so separating the two
hemispheres one of the two hemispheres
is put in a solution that preserves it
the other hemisphere will be dissected
in thick sections and those will be
frozen we are not even close to
understand a lot of what we take for
granted our thoughts were instincts our
feelings our emotions there are a lot of
questions we still don't know and a lot
of our brain functions still will
probably be studied for a long time to
come
a brain donation is in a very concrete
way a gift of knowledge and it cannot be
done without the help of families and
people willing to donate a brain
[Music]
I'll do some training I worked with dogs
to train them to go into an MRI scanner
and try to figure out what makes them
tick and what they're thinking
my name is Gregory Berns
I'm a neuroscientist at Emory University
in Atlanta Georgia I've grown up with
dogs and I've lived with dogs pretty
much my whole life one of my favorite
dogs had passed away in the back of my
mind I started wondering did that dog
love me in the way that I loved him and
that was really the beginning of it all
of these basic things that we've begun
to sort out in humans at least in human
brands we want to do in dogs if dogs can
be trained to go into an MRI machine and
then maybe we could figure out what
they're actually thinking so we have a
dog in a scanner that's Katie and she is
a veteran of the project this is
probably about the 15th of times she's
done this
[Music]
just having the idea of ok well let's
train dogs on the scanner it wasn't
immediately apparent how you would go
about doing that and and MRI scanners
are not the most pleasant environments
Callie is the little black terrier who
was the first dog to train for the dog
project I built a simulator of an MRI so
this is the simulator the I built here
in my basement
then we started adding in recordings of
the scanner noise which is actually
quite loud we just started working with
you know treats and positive
reinforcement to see if we could get her
to go into this thing that actually
proved to be pretty easy and then so
what we did was we kind of put out word
of mouth do you want to join this
project you want to train your dogs for
an MRI and you know maybe figure out
what they're thinking the purpose of
this is to go through a number of
exercises including basic obedience as
well as how they react to the obstacles
when we hold the tryouts it lets us weed
out the dogs that we don't think would
enjoy doing this one of the benefits
then of having more participants as it
gives you statistical power you can
start to average dogs brains together
and get a better sense for what's
happening I started wondering very
seriously if we could really finally
answer this question do dogs essentially
like us just for the social bond and not
about the food
and what we found was looking at the
reward system that almost all the dogs
had equal responses both to food as well
as praise and even a few dogs like the
praise more the things that we were
finding about the dog's brain in many
ways confirm I think what people know in
their hearts about how dogs behave and
why they behave the way I think about
dogs is in many ways they're the
ambassadors to the animal world they're
not that different from many of the
other mammals out there and so I suspect
that a lot of what we find is dogs
probably holds true for pretty much any
mammal
[Music]
have you ever walked out of a building
on a sunny day and had an uncontrollable
urge to sneeze if you answered yes like
me you likely suffer from a strange
genetic condition that has remained
unexplained by medical science for
millennia and if you answered no you
probably have no idea what I'm talking
about son sneezing as it's more commonly
known is a medical condition called the
photic sneeze reflex hold on before we
get into all that this is dr. Lewis
pootatuck a neurologist and human
geneticist at the University of
California San Francisco okay go ahead
another name that some have given is
autosomal dominant compelling helio
ophthalmic outburst or I choose Engram
but PSR is really the appropriate name
that we should all use Botox knees
reflexes a tendency to sneeze when
suddenly exposed to bright lights and as
strange as that may sound it's more
common than you might think I asked a
mate that about 1 in 10 or 10 percent of
all people have this condition so a lot
of us are affected but how and why it
happens is not fully understood despite
the fact that humans have been pondering
it for thousands of years in 350 BC
Aristotle posed the question why does
the heat of the Sun provoke sneezing
Aristotle was barking up the wrong tree
though this doesn't make sense because
heat in and of itself doesn't it causing
some 2,000 years later the philosopher
Sir Francis Bacon also tried to figure
it out his theory was that light from
the Sun caused your eyes to water which
then seep into your nose triggering a
sneeze it's an interesting thought but
it doesn't make a lot of sense
PSR occurs almost instantaneously and it
takes longer for the tear ducts to react
furthermore tears don't cause anything
there's no evidence for that so modern
medicine has come up with its own
theories and it has to do with the
wiring in your head
sneezes are triggered typically by
irritating things in our nose and these
are detected by a nerve the trigeminal
nerve and right next door to the
trigeminal nerve is the optic nerve you
may have heard of this one the optic
nerve is stimulated by bright lights and
sends electric signals to the brain some
of that signals can be picked up by the
cry geminal nerve and misinterpreted by
the brain as an irritation in the nose
which triggers you guessed it a sneeze
well that's the theory anyway photic
sneeze reflex is not a disease
consequently the medical community
hasn't paid a whole lot of attention to
it therefore we know very little about
what causes it but dr. patashnik
believes that understanding PSR could
potentially shut some light on more
serious conditions epileptic seizures
can be caused by strobing lights
migraine headache is precipitated by
light if we can understand what the
mechanism is that leads to PSR this may
give insight into other conditions which
actually are medically important and
represent disorders so there you have it
this 2,000 year old medical mystery may
be worth solving after all
imagine remembering every single day of
your life all in perfect detail for
those with highly superior
autobiographical memory or H Sam for
short this is their reality I remember
everything that's personally happened to
me since I was born
that's Rebecca sharukh I was fascinated
by this condition so I called her up to
find out more hi Rebecca hi how are you
going I'm doing all right
it's a very wet Saturday morning here
how are you going side note in this
moment I just realized Rebecca will
remember that this day was a wet morning
forever so you remember everything in
great detail people can remember what
they did last Saturday but I can
remember what I did Saturday ten years
ago what about a memory from when you
uttered the baby when I was 12 days old
I was lying down on the fur car seat in
my parents car and I was staring up at
the steering wheel and I thought what is
that Rebecca is one of only 60 people
worldwide to have been identified with
having hate sin all through my teenage
years I thought that everybody
remembered in this kind of way I thought
it was completely normal it wasn't until
she was 21 when her parents decided to
submit her to the University of
California to undergo two years of
testing after this she was officially
identified as having H Sam since
memories can come to mind unexpectedly
any time of day a negative memory like
this can make living with HCM difficult
mum was porting me in
this Ichi satin dress and I was crying
because I didn't like it and mum gave me
this Minnie Mouse toy and I couldn't say
anything at the time but her face
terrified me but on most days eh Sam as
a gift
Rebecca can recall happy memories and
moments when times get tough a good
memory it makes me so thankful about
having this kind of patience and memory
thanks for telling Rebecca yep
[Music]